I have to say and and it would have be
absurd to me if I lost my relationship
with my boyfriend over politics I think
that would be absurd yet it's come close
it's come close at times certainly this
summer of 2018 when everything looked
like it was blowing up and the Cavanaugh
hearings were happening and we were on
separate sides that I thought the count
on hearings were a joke a complete joke
he thought she was a hero heroine a
heroine that I thought was insane so
[Music]
since you told me that nothing's off
topic and you already brought him up so
you mentioned so your part you say
partner
what's a partner is a partner that
always reminds me my boyfriend boyfriend
partner always seems like you're playing
tennis - he was boyfriend for golf or
something or he was a boyfriend for two
years and now it's been going on 11 he's
a partner now yeah he moved it to
partner
he's partner fair enough so my husband
so he's a Bernie guy and I was burning
obviously or not and I think that's
super interesting we had dinner one
night the four of us and I didn't super
interesting because I get a lot of email
from people that are breaking up over
this kind of stuff right other marriages
I've had people email me that they have
had divorces or are in the midst of a
divorce because of this yeah you guys
can some help sir work past that I think
look because politics are not the B land
all even though many people might feel
that way in in this crazy environment
and atmosphere that we're living in I
won't allow it I simply won't allow it
and I don't think he will allow it
either I mean in terms we like each
other more than that right but is that
generally easier first from do you think
someone coming from your perspective
then usually the leftist percentage we
don't have to make this about your
boyfriend specifically your partner but
you know to me like I find people that
are coming from it from a Moroso
politics is in everything perspective
can let a lot of stuff go versus oh yeah
a lot of lefties they think politics is
everything right they believe that this
thing is everything look
I am of that of that of that demo I will
not let politics destroy a relationship
and I will not let it destroy a
friendship at all I had dinner last
night with three friends who are on the
right who were conservative I'm having
dinner tomorrow night with three friends
who are Democrat and heavily SoCal
liberals I moved through both worlds and
I will never define a friend or not have
a friend based on other politics I
simply won't do it only disinvites
someone a bit based on their bothers is
absurd though of course this has
happened and it's happened to me through
this book and through my podcast even
though I am NOT a vocal trump supporter
and I what I do is I I've been
criticized in the media and I've been
criticizing people have been losing
their minds over Trump that gets you
disinvited a lot of stuff so that be
clear you yeah you mean you talk about
since you didn't even vote for Trump
right but so much of the book related to
it's not enough yeah it's not enough you
have to call your face off you have to
call your facebook but anyway I have to
say and and it would have be absurd to
me if I lost my relationship with my
boyfriend over politics I think that
would be absurd yet it's come close it's
come close at times certainly the summer
of 2018 when everything looked like it
was blowing up and the Cavanaugh
hearings were happening and we were on
separate sides that I thought the count
on hearings were a drunk a complete joke
he thought she was a hero heroine a
heroine that I thought was insane I
thought it was absolutely insane and so
we did get to a couple of you know
whisper screaming arguments and in
pavilions or whatever you know it was
just nuts and I was I could barely drive
the car because we were screaming at
each other over this and I couldn't
believe how fast it would come on it
wasn't a slow burn it will go one two
hundred in like five seconds and you're
screaming at each other over this you
cannot believe how one person's happy at
the same time you know you take a deep
breath and you realize what is this
about what is this about
and I and I will say I am the more
mature one I don't say anything anymore
I just keep it closed a new suck it up
and say you're the more mature he was
saying some things about Bernie and
about Trump but just like you know
maybe you know so I am I'm but I can't
imagine letting politics define not only
my love life or my friendships yeah not
gonna happen
so all the people that when they've gone
crazy one of the guys who helped frame
some of this for me do you know Michael
malleus by any chance I don't know if it
is it he's an interesting guy you'd like
a lot he's a he's really sort of a he's
even at Fir he's not even a libertarian
he's more of like an an cap you know no
government he like he likes kind of
chaos like I call him the Willy Wonka of
politics he's just kind of outright a
really really interesting thinker but he
loves the tumult that were in right now
uh-huh where I think my default is a
little more if everyone could just calm
down yeah that's a little bit better oh
yeah but I but I would imagine though
also as a writer and generally as a
creative person it's like you kind of
have to like it a little bit if you're
gonna be able to get anything done right
I think like if you were hating this
entire thing right now do you think you
could be creative through it I actually
do hate a lot of it yeah I really do
hate a lot of it and I and it's not it's
not again beside that elected Trump that
I hate I really do hate what's become of
the other side of the aisle that's
really my problem and that's what makes
me so sad and depressing me all the time
is that there is this complete absence
of connection of wanting to connect and
wanting to stem this divide that's
happening wanting to mend mend at
something and I do think that the media
is at fault a huge part of his at fault
I don't think brush and BOTS are there
to blame for anything the media must be
blamed for really sowing the seeds of
just discord and the fact that my
friends on the Left cannot speak to
somebody often on the right is a problem
I think there was some poll taken where
92% of people on the right would have
yeah a little over 8% of liberals would
have a conservative whatever that is I
really do see that I see that around LA
and I see that around the people that I
know in New York that that actually
makes me depressed that is a depressing
thing it doesn't make me happy to be
alive or to be a writer
and a lot of what I'm writing right now
really has nothing to do with any of
this I'm writing a novel that said in
1980
I am writing another novel is based on
an intellectual property so I don't know
if there's anything about this period
that I necessarily want to write write
about I do think that it is kind of a
very depressing stressful period to a
degree I'm a lot older so I kind of let
it go up run off me but you know there
is stress floating around everywhere
yeah are you surprised how its worldwide
now that it feel it's not just you know
little la bubble it's not just a little
American thing that it seems to be
everywhere now well look I was surprised
that this book was being published in as
many countries as it was because it's
nonfiction and it seems to be
specifically about the United States and
what's been going on the last five or
ten years here culturally politically to
a degree but I did two tours of France
for this book because they see the same
thing kind of happening Kancil culture
is rearing its head political
correctness to an almost frightening
degree and a cultural appropriation is
starting to also rear its head the me2
movement is being weaponized in ways
that go against whatever its initial
promise was when it began and a lot of
people were getting worried certainly
when I was touring through Italy of all
places the same concerns that all of the
these things that we're talking about
here is kind of sweeping along Europe at
least throughout Europe and that
nationalism for another thing is
sweeping along Europe as well which of
course drives you know your average
liberal plate insane but look but but
also I mean what is being recorded I
mean what is being recorded or reported
I mean you know the elections in Israel
not been the last few days can your
cricket if about anything about the
novel I mean anything right and it seems
I mean and the way the headlines were in
the New York Times and the LA Times were
might be looks like it instead of like
you know decisively saying that this has
happened so I I don't know I mean I
think we're in a very weird place
in terms of how we're getting our
information and how we're getting our
mation from everywhere so like you're
saying yes around the world this
whatever this might be yeah it's
happening do you think maybe we're
starting to enter a time when we won't
need institutions the way we needed them
so you mention the New York Times and
CNN before these things that core
pillars that we all believed in and
maybe that's part of why other people
are just like yes and it's all becoming
neat I'm seeing so much [ __ ] drop away
from me so much stuff that I used to
believe in that I used to watch that I
used to read just dropping away from me
because of really most of the time a
kind of bias that I smell and I can't
deal with so I find a lot of that just
dropping away from me so yes this is a
risk though if they all crumble well
interesting what's the risk well the
risk being that if all the institutions
crumble the things that sort of link us
to something kind of mainstream that the
Overton Window will be is so blown away
that we're just gonna have factions of
people constantly warring over what is
actually true because there will be no
institutions that are able to thank you
you know I do think that's happening and
I've started to come to belief that
maybe that is the only alternative but
but I do think maybe for a democracy to
work you still need usually sort of
function you think you're having the New
York Times being no I'm not really no
understand the grey lady country is
really healthy I don't know I don't
either we don't if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell